hey everyone
welcome
bentino massaro's direct path
bentino has been one of the
most profound influences
on my god realization
and my understanding of the
landscape
of who we are why we're here
where we're going the nature of reality
consciousness
the absolute infinity
from what i understand he
during his
adolescent years underwent
glimpses of what it means
to be enlightened
and then underwent travels
to india and
found a lot of wisdom in the yoga sutras
of patanjali
as we've talked about a lot on the show
with yoga
chitta vritti nirodha
so union is the
stopping of the fluctuations of mind
and then went on to
have more and more of this
expansive satori
which then he felt confident enough
almost 10 years ago now there are some
videos of him
that are that old where he's sharing
what he experienced
and if i understand correctly that would
be approximately around the age of 22 or
so
and that's really young for being able
to
pierce the veilless veil and
god realize
and then furthermore is in those next
couple of years from about 22 to
appearing like 25 or so
passing a good amount of time at putting
together
the understandings
into a modern
teaching he's a spiritual synthesis
as am i pulling from a lot of the
different
mystic traditions finding the perennial
wisdom the many paths to the one truth
and that's why he really resonates with
me
actually that's why people like rupert
spyra as well really resonate with me
eckhart tolle basically the people that
are
most perennial fred davis we just
had on the show
and bentino also focuses a lot on true
simultaneity which i was first taught by
sri aurobindo
about simultaneity being key
and so that's another key resonating
factor
is that simultaneity which will unpack
in a bit
so he undergoes this process of putting
together
the understandings which here is one of
the graphics
of and we'll have a couple of these
graphics throughout
and we'll go over some of the higher
level teachings towards the end so we're
going to do
a boot camp version of the direct path
and then we'll do a an advanced level
towards the end
covering some of the most cutting-edge
ground that he's been
understanding most recently
and so you can find the links in the bio
below to
his website as well as his mirror talk
series which is on youtube which does a
really good job at unpacking these
insights in more detail as well as the
rest of his global enlightenment retreat
that he had
on his youtube channel and also his
instagram
as well as
who is making some of the graphics that
we'll be sharing
towards the end at a really high level
of quotes and other inspirational
understandings of his
so in essence he's putting together his
understandings
into a coherent framework for people to
become
god realized
now the breaking it up into these
components of being self
or god realized versus being self
actualized being empowered
he breaks it up into these components
but ultimately becoming god realized
is also becoming empowered and becoming
a more effortless action wu way with
your
self actualization with your own unique
artistic expression
where you butterfly affect only the
absolute highest morality
so putting together these types of
graphics
and doing these sat songs he would have
these
group gatherings where it would be about
god realization and you would break it
down into different topics this is about
what appeared to be about six or so
years ago so maybe around 2015
it looked like he was doing these very
frequently and
i believe he was approximately 26 or so
years old
then as well so i'm 28
so he's 26 and he's
already put together this massive
curricula
and as you can see it's there in the
bottom right corner
trinfinityacademy.com
and over these last especially you know
six years has been building up this
massive catalog of content not only
with this teaching but also on bentino
massaro.tv where he has a
subscription service to this massive
catalog of content that he has
and this is because he's had all of
these opportunities to be able to sit
down and pass along
his teachings to people that are
interested in god realization and
because he
himself is god realized he himself
understands that topology or that
landscape to the nature of reality
and so because of that that enables him
to be able to
create those containers where people can
tell based on his vibration
based on his essence based on his
frequency
based on what he is saying because it's
a perennial wisdom
you know when you know and you know when
other people know
and so he would do things like take
graphics like this and then explain
them and unpack them and answer
questions for an hour hour and a half
and this would be a way for the teaching
in a sense to become formulated by the
teacher and the students themselves in
dialectic
very socratic
and that's been the classic relationship
which is what nisargadatta maharaj who
is a major
teacher of bentino's as well talked
about the
salience the most important thing
is to surround yourself with those that
are enlightened those that
have underwent satori or sahaja or
nirvana or moksha
because that liberation from suffering
from them them being god realized
themselves
it butterfly effects out onto you it's
as simple as just
their peace their happiness their
understanding of the
god being the seer or consciousness or
awareness itself
is enough for you to slowly ease your
way or rapidly
again that's the answer the bird's way
of sahara meshwar
who was actually teaching this maharaja
and so either one of those may come
in terms of antsway or bird's way but to
actually know
who these people are and to go out and
consume the content that they're
providing for free
online is sit so paramount
this is what i did in 2020 was just eat
up as much sponge up as much of this
cutting edge content around god
realization around studying the
geniuses that have lived before us
and that are alive today and abstract
out a meta pattern of their most
profound teachings
and so to be that obsessed with truth is
going to make it yield
and of course
he's had
these obstacles and adversities as he's
been
becoming more well-known in the space
there's a lot of
especially when you're in your mid-20s
there's a lot of
although it may feel like the ego is
completely transcended
that there are a lot of perverse
incentives
around what is known as the guru
disciple relationship
and so if the student is seeking
and if the guru is truly enriched
then there won't be any tension between
them in the sense of monetary or
sexual or clout
based that type of stuff because
the person that is enlightened or
awakened
understands the nature of reality to
such a degree where those experiences
just
slide off of them
then he's had some scenarios with people
that
have underwent more damaging
instances to themselves as well as with
having people come
and be
in a sense very misrepresenting about
what his
essence is on videos and documentaries
and things like that
of course there have been bold claims by
bentino as well
but this is the learning process you can
tell that there's a new
level of maturity in what he's doing
from what i understand i think he's
32 right now and so
this is also quite nice for me as well
hitting this
liberation around 28
which is then giving me this higher
level of maturity
as i enter into a similar space
especially coming from a viewpoint of
understanding
the deep sciences and understanding
the synthesis of spirituality with that
and
what we're doing with artificial general
intelligence where we're at
geopolitically
all of this type of stuff so it's its
own unique angle
and it's nearly in a sense
it's impossible for you not to color
your understanding
of reality or the absolute with your own
units personality your own unique
refraction the source light coming
through
your diamond necklace around your neck
but to do your best to not get attached
to these things
and that's one of the perennial wisdoms
to not get attached to these words
even in these graphics that we're going
to unpack here
even in our teachings ourself on our
direct path videos
there's never a obsession with
specific words
it's experience based for you to
recognize that diamond necklace around
your neck and god realize
so a little bit of backstory on him
and a little bit of also gratitude for
the very
fact that 10 years ago there was that
courageous
stepping forward and taking the satori
and being able to share it with people
over all of these years across all of
this video host all of these retreats
and getting people to god realize likely
hundreds and hundreds of people across
the world god realized now
because of bentino stepping forward and
sharing
many of these direct path teachings and
putting it so concisely
so very grateful super grateful
so let's jump in so if we take a look at
this first graphic this first graphic is
one that
aims to summarize the entire
metaphysical landscape
so the entire metaphysical landscape is
best
addressed by the
that first quadrant on the right
so you have that quadrant or that slice
all the way on the right
and it's the i am this slice
the person beingness impermanent focused
experiencing subject
objects now
the individual self creation what's
happening
is that
there's a human that
understands that okay
it depends on how they're raised because
if you're raised like a kogi mama
and you never ever even have the egoic
contracted energetic entity form in the
first place
you will literally only be that
awareness you will only be
on that infinite absolute
and awareness side of things
now the i am this only happens because
we have
ignorant parenting that
when the child comes into the world the
child is immediately told that they are
separate
that they gain these layers of identity
the object permanence kicks in
all of these types of things happen that
then make it so that the child has to
undergo this process of shedding
their layers of ego later on in their
lives
and so that's what happens is the child
is born into the world they think it's a
physical
finite
earth that has
a that that's the limit of the picture
is that
that there's all these separate egoic
entities across
this planet and that they have to have
this fear in the safety mechanism
and that it's just
all upside down and backwards but that's
the whole point of the creation that's
the whole point of lila the divine play
and so when that happens usually
they're trapped in the i am this i
am this body i am this onion layer of my
identity my where i'm born what my age
is what my name is
what i do for a living where i live all
these onion layers of identity you're
always associating yourself with your
thoughts or your emotions or your
perceptions your sensations or these
objects or anything like that
and it's that obsessive compulsive
inability to
quiet your own mind that is driving the
monkey mind
absolutely out of control and it's not
giving you access to the nature of
reality that is
already around your neck the diamond is
already here
you just don't know because you're stuck
in the clouds instead of understanding
what the sky
is and so that's what the i am this is
the i am this is all of the myriad
clouds that are happening
and so that's when you get things like
when suffering happens to the human the
suffering is
like a guidance system it's like that
resonance that is trying to say
hey wake up wake up
if you're suffering right now you don't
have to because your nature
is happiness your nature is peace so why
don't you have that
it's already around your neck how do you
not know that maybe there is something
for you to do
maybe there is something for you to seek
maybe there is
an optimal direct path for you to become
enlightened that takes into account all
of these perennial wisdoms across the
mystic traditions
and so that's the process of
tuning in to suffering as a drill
sergeant
suffering as a guidance system getting
you to burst
out of physicalism getting you to burst
out of being a finite contracted egoic
entity and seeking something greater
than that
now it's not like the parable of the
prodigal son where you go
outward and then you keep going outward
and keep going outward
because it is like that in the sense
that you're going to keep going outward
and then you're going to be seeking
happiness externally
and you're going to hit a breaking point
and then you're going to turn inward
but it's not like that in the sense that
you don't immediately turn inward
people seek for really long periods of
time without understanding
to turn into their consciousness into
their awareness itself that that is
where the seed of god
is god is the seer people don't
recognize that right away nobody's
telling them that right away
so even me when i'm 23 attending
theravada buddhism
10-day meditation retreats you know
nobody's telling me
then either that god is the seer
nobody's telling me there that there are
these levels like with this graphic here
where you can actually visually see the
entire landscape
or the topology of what the nature of
reality is
nobody is showing this to us
you get these nice experiential
exercises which are incredible
at learning how to eradicate the deepest
roots of suffering because you
shut your mouth for 10 straight days and
you can't make eye contact or use
technology
and so you're able to go down to those
deepest roots
of suffering and misery and absolutely
eradicate them and liberate them
you're you're using your breath as a
mechanism as a tool for you to do so you
create this massive gap
so you're not reactive you're not
craving or averting it's really powerful
and useful
entheogens are really powerful and
useful that was something that i also
started dabbling into
with lsd and psilocybin and five emo dmt
and doing other things like beginning to
read things reading the doubted qing
reading the old and new testament
reading the sufi metaphysics
reading the four books five classics
undergoing more and more different
shamanic rituals
more and more learning from people like
bentino masaro or rupert spyra
or sria robindo and so
looking up the life of buddha of adi
shankara of patanjali
of jesus christ of
laotsa and of confucius
and so this is sort of the thing that
you have to do in a sense if you want to
become a synthesis
if you want to be able to have a robust
lattice work
across all of these different mystic
traditions you have to take the
spiritual synthesis route
because it's what gives you the untrue
anchored understanding of what perennial
wisdom is
philosophia means the love of wisdom
that's why it's perennial wisdom because
it's across all
of the mystic traditions they all have
the same wisdom it's many paths to one
end it's the perennial philosophy
and this is what we'll get into towards
the end but this is where things like
the traditions of things like the
the existing frameworks with things like
the neo advaita
where that sort of one step to the
absolute
is in a sense a little more unstable
which we'll get to in a moment
so actually what we can do here is we
can go to this graphic again and we can
look at what's called the first step
okay so
the first step is when what we're
talking about with that parable of the
prodigal son where you no longer seek
externally
you're no longer a contracted goku
entity because you're drawn to seek
towards something that's greater than
just being a finite biological creature
which is not your nature
you are not that you know nettie netty i
am not a finite biological creature
you know you have to have this
discernment basically on all the time
your vigilance is what is key to your
discernment which is what is key to your
enlightenment
and in this case you're no longer
seeking externally but now you're
turned inward so that's typically the
first step
so not only not not it's not always a
turn directly inward sometimes it's
seeking other things
but ultimately it's a turn inward in
order to understand
and again we i didn't have this
nomenclature i didn't have this lexicon
this vocabulary
and so now you get it you get these
graphics
you get the i'm doing an exegesis
i'm drawing out bentino masaro's most
profound wisdoms on his direct path
teaching
and then i'm distilling it even further
for you
now you don't have to go out and search
for this graphic you don't have to go
look for this landscape
i already drew it out for you from his
work and now i'm sharing it with you so
now you get to hack
you get a rare candy like you're in
pokemon you get to level up faster
and so recognize that recognize that
because if i was 23 years old
and if somebody was able to provide me
with
radical insights like this along with
the theravada buddhism and sit down
with me and undergo this process i could
have rocketed faster
and so this is what we need for five
year olds 12 year olds 18 year olds
we need these styles of rocketing up
faster to god realization
and then to solve the greatest
sustainable development goals and
challenges that our planet has for
maximizing prosperity abundance
well-being flourishing
human potential at large
all right so you undergo this process of
having that
that suffering as a drill sergeant that
is constantly being like
you know you are not that cloud you know
that cloud that is your thought or your
emotion or your belief or your
feeling that you are not that
that this finite egoic contracted energy
is constantly assuming
that i am my thought i am this emotion
it's ridiculous it's absolutely absurd
when you get to this point
it is so absurd you're not even that
person anymore
i don't even know who that guy was i
can't even believe it it's crazy
and so you recognize that you're not
that cloud
you're not that thought feeling emotion
and then what happens is you recognize
that you're the sky
the sky is what is known as that i am
so it's not i am this it's i am
and these analogies we've been using on
the show so much you know one that
rupert's been
really influential with us on is this is
the i am the i am is the blank [ __ ]
paper
and the i am this is when the paper gets
colored by
words so here are the papers colored by
words the words are the clouds
the words are the clouds the paper
itself pure bear empty awareness or
consciousness
this is the sky this is eternally being
colored by experience
no [ __ ] okay so now you're starting to
get it
now i didn't get that awareness or
consciousness was it
until just over a little over a month
ago
i didn't i didn't know that that that
was the diamond necklace that
roomie was talking about consciousness
and awareness
is eternal it is what is being colored
by experience all the time
and you can also use the ocean analogy
here as well so you begin recognizing
the i
am this is when you're experiencing a
wave of emotion or
feeling or belief or experience or
thought or perception sensation object
what
have you and the ocean is the infinite
consciousness or the infinite awareness
itself
so you become that i am witness that i
am observer that is then
recognizing that that experience is like
a cloud
otherwise if you're the i am this if
you're the contracted physical entity
you become the cloud and the cloud is
you and you're lost in the cloud
you're lost in the wave you're lost in
the words
or in the most modern understanding as
well you have these devices
your awareness your consciousness is the
eternal screen
that is being colored by experiences
guys this stuff is not that difficult
it's so funny it's hilarious it's the
vales veiler the gateless gate it is
that
simple it is that much recognition that
is needed
of course you will also be building up
this lattice work which will help you a
lot this concept
framework of schemas across different
perennial wisdoms
but to just understand the turn inward
is so paramount
stop looking externally stop your monkey
mind from racing for just
one moment and just recognize
your pure bear awareness the
consciousness itself before it gets
colored by a cloud
that sky is what we're talking about as
the diamond necklace that's around your
neck
that consciousness that awareness is
shared you and i
share our consciousness every single one
of us on the planet
shares our consciousness our awareness
that is what non-duality
is is that sharedness of our
consciousness that is what
love is the sharedness of the
consciousness it is not
the separate 8 billion entities
but it is the non-duality of that
consciousness or awareness being shared
now do we have unique diamonds around
our necks that the source light is
refracting through
yes we do if you look at our eye the eye
itself has a pupil right and that's the
shared
eye of god but the iris around it is the
unique coloration of the diamond that
the source light is refracting through
so do you have a unique experience of
course you do do i have a unique
experience of course i do
but the i when you ask the most
fundamental [ __ ] question
what is i the answer to that question
is god the i is god the i
is source the i
is brahman or dao that's what it is
and it's infinitely and eternally being
colored
by experience that's what that's what it
means by god's dream that this
is the dream this is the appearance
the physicalism creation design is the
appearance
and within it we get colored by
experience
just like we do when we go sleep at
night you sleep for eight
hours a night and for several of those
hours you probably dream you simulate
realities immerse yourself in first
person and you go and walk around in
them
that is what this is wake up to that
it's that simple
is right under our noses all of these
codes are right under our noses
and so that's what the i am is the i am
is the presence beingness
permanent relaxed experiencing subject
object
it's the presence energy substratum all
that is the manifest self
so to recognize that
you are that that's what tatvam asi
means it means that you are that i am
that we
are that what does i and my father are
one
mean from john 10 30 it means that
i and god are one it's not two
it's one that's what non-duality means
it means it is one
not two what does waddat al-wuju the
sufi metaphysic means it means that
everybody on the [ __ ] planet all a
billion of us are going through our own
unique styles
of piercing the veilless veil and
finding the diamond necklace already
around our neck
which is what happened to me about a
month ago i pierced
the veilless veil i [ __ ] got it i had
the satori
now i'm just building up on top of that
now now i'm able to actually communicate
these things to you because i [ __ ]
get it i understand it i'm god realized
great and i'm gonna continue doing these
bicep curls
these workouts that are going to
continue making me more and more
understanding
of what the true topology landscape of
the nature of reality is and sharing it
with people
there's nothing else i could do that's
what is happening to this creative
expression of infinity
i'm not doing anything it's doing me and
that's a whole nother step
for you to recognize is that you're not
doing it it's doing you
but the ego wants to have the illusion
of control
so now ramana maharshi will tell you
that
you go to the stage of the i i which is
this next
stage on the left which is the
unmanifest self
that's where you have the awareness
the emptiness beingness the timeless the
self-experiencing
pure subject no object so that's when
you get to
really get into the
awareness aware of awareness that's what
ramana maharshi meant
and that's why he just stayed silent
because that's what he did
all the time was just be aware of
awareness
itself and that's it that's it your god
realized you're aware of awareness
itself
done done
now people would come up to him and they
would maybe ask a question and he would
stay silent why
because just being in his energy being
in his aura even that question itself
you would be looking at ramana
as he's literally just being god
realized he's just
he's just shining from his eyes and
radiating the absolute god rely state
there's nothing else that can happen to
you besides that butterfly effect of you
also becoming more and more recognized
that that is it
look at this guy look at how happy look
at how peaceful it is is that the nature
of awareness
yes it's the nature of awareness and
it's being colored by experience
it's very much like the
pure bear empty nest
you're getting to a point where more and
more the perennial wisdom across the
mystic traditions of
nirvana or being blown out or moksha
being liberated from
suffering or sahaja the sudden
sudden enlightenment is kicking in
where you're really starting to be like
whoa
what is this all about because the i
am phase is
already [ __ ] mind-blowing enough
and when you're getting closer and
closer to the infinite when you're
getting closer to the absolute to even
beyond the eye when you transcend even
the observer the witness
the self god itself
you're really getting into some insane
places that are
absolutely ineffable you can't use words
you can't even use
concepts can't use descriptions there's
nothing you can do
to explain what it's like to transcend
awareness itself
well bentino did hear he wrote you know
the one
the absolute infinity beyond i beyond
this foreverness beyond experiencing and
no subject and that's
ultimately you know the best we can do
the best we can do is these types of
words
and the easiest way to get there again
is to just transcend
even the observer itself transcend even
the witness itself
even awareness itself transcend even
that recognize that that
is the the god or the brahmana or the
dao
or the source point
and yet there's even something to
transcend beyond that
beyond your awareness itself
so we go through this process of
recognizing that
all the way there is this contracted
egoic entity and it undergoes this
process of awakening
to these next stages that are more and
more relaxing
and they're more and more expansive it's
just a relaxation and expansion that
happens
all right so i'm going to show you now
another way to view
that person world okay so this is
another way
to view the person world so you have
that consciousness which is very much
like that i
am-ness and that i am-ness is the most
pure bear empty awareness
that is it okay now beyond that
is where you begin coloring your
layers of identity you take the sky
and you instead of recognizing and
staying as the sky experiencing the
clouds you become more and more attached
to your clouds they become you your
clouds become
your layers of identity so here when you
move up from consciousness into things
like
the points of view in a sense this is
even moving down you become more and
more constricted egoically
into your points of view or into your
unconscious beliefs
into your subconscious feelings into
your conscious thoughts
you become more and more contracted
you are not your thought you are not
your feeling you are not your emotion
you are not your belief you are not your
experience your sensation your
perception you are none of those things
you are not the clouds you are the sky
which is the consciousness itself
and so to be able to see things like
this it slowly can help you go from that
physical world
to that next layer of the at least the i
am-ness
itself recognizing yourself as the
observer as the witness
as the diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
that is what that means that is what
roomy meant
alright so hopefully that helps a bit
with the direct path i'm going to show
share this graphic with you as well
which is basically another one of
sort of bentino's syntheses on the
nature of reality
in another perspective which
this one you can find in his global
enlightenment retreat again that
physical
is the box that's around your head
the physical is every single lie that
you've been told
every single subscription that's
happened to you that's created a layer
of identity
complete lies absolute complete lies
and that's that's the indoctrination and
the baptizing that happens in the
culture of physicalism and the religion
of
physicalism
and if you don't have conscious parents
if you have ignorant parents they're
gonna baptize you even harder into
physicalism
and then you're gonna have to shed those
onion layers so you as you're probably
going to be having kids as well
if you are younger and listening that
you your number one priority should be
to become awakened and enlightened and
become a conscious parent
so that you don't funnel your kid into
an egoic physical
box around their head and so what
becomes a little more subtle so the
physical is the gross
and then you move your way up to the
absolute which becomes more and more
subtle
so in this sense you get up to this mind
the mind
is more subtle than the physical and you
recognize that that's a pretty simple
transition
for you to go okay you go
this to your thought that's a layer of
subtlety and difference
and then you go another layer up to
nothingness which means rather than
being the sky
rather than being the clouds the clouds
of the thoughts emotions feelings
perceptions sensations experiences
etc rather than having your mind
be in those clouds and obser
obsessed with them now you take a step
back and you recognize that the
awakeness
itself that awareness that consciousness
itself
is pure bear empty there's no
thing there it's not a thing it's a
subject it's an observer it's a witness
itself now you go one more step back in
subtlety and you get to the awareness of
everything all eight billion humans
in this creation design across all of
these different creation designs
themselves
and that's when you can really hold the
integral if you're holding not only the
eight billion here but you're holding
the
every single creation design and all of
the agents there that are piercing the
veil
the veilless veil and awakening to their
true nature that's what it means
the unity of all finding is happening
this fast across all these
creation designs and so it's not only
awareness of your
own creation design here of 8 billion so
you're literally holding the
consciousness of
all eight billion people as one
consciousness of god which it
is but you're doing that across all
creation designs
all that is okay and that's when you can
transcend
even the observer even the witness
itself and
that's when there's this question mark
absolute infinity
here's another way that bentino says it
it's really profound
if people can't hear you are that one
infinite absolute formless perfection
beyond all experience
i move on to you are pure awareness
again let's
say that one more time if people can't
hear you are that
one infinite absolute formless
perfection beyond all experience
i move on to you are pure awareness so
that's your tip top
one infinite absolute formless
perfection beyond all experience
okay hold that re-read that practice
that over and over again
so if you can't hear that move on to you
are pure awareness
if they cannot hear that i suggest they
focus on being present
beyond their ordinary thoughts okay
so again quite simple just
be present as the sky or the ocean
itself
rather than the clouds or the waves it's
that simple
just get to that point beyond
physicalism and you're already
in the hands of eternity and infinity at
a deeper level
if they cannot hear that i suggest they
discover their calling slash purpose and
align everything to it
so if you don't have any idea what we're
talking about regarding
transcending physicalism to become the
observer or the witness or that i
am-ness if you have no idea what that is
and you don't care and you don't want to
investigate further then just align
yourself to your calling and purpose in
your self-actualization route
and go and make a profound valuable
impact on the world hopefully you're
solving
some sustainable development goals and
maximizing planetary harmony and
prosperity and peace and love
if they cannot hear that i say they can
create whatever they want
if they cannot hear that i am forced by
their free will to hand what feels like
my children
back to the sinister hypnotists who have
curated mass ignorance for millennia
i release them with a blessing an armor
of love and light
and a new seed planted in their being to
awaken them over time
so this is a
this is a homeomorphism of the
other graphics that we've been looking
at so the homeomorphism
simply means that it's topologically
isomorphic
so meaning this is topologically the
same as what we saw through the other
graphics
so it's just another way to portray the
data
so in this case bentino is explaining it
with words
but it's the same thing as when you saw
the graphic earlier
so it's the same thing but just
displayed differently it's the same data
the same information displayed
differently
that's why it's called a homeomorphism
these things are topologically
isomorphic
so again here's the example with words
then you have this example from the
global enlightenment retreat that he
just did this last year
in 2020
and then you have this which is again
from i believe even this is old from six
years ago or something which is so
crazy it's so cool that he was here in
2015 trying to bring this to the masses
and that's sharing the same thing as we
saw in those other graphics and then
this one is just that version of what
it's like on the physicalism level
trying to transcend that into the
simple i am pure consciousness or
awareness
okay so just to make sure everybody is
up to speed we will review one more time
what this atlas
unit is communicating with the direct
path it's not different than bentino
massaro it's not different than rupert
spyra
it's not different than fred davis it's
not different than
any of the teachers of
non-duality it's not different than any
of the
spiritual synthesis that are on the
planet eckhart tolle
and all of these guys they're all
pointing the same thing rumi was
pointing the same thing that lautza was
pointing to
buddha's pointing the same thing that
jesus christ is pointing to
everybody's pointing to the same thing
they're having different
colors as they're talking about it but
they're pointing to the same thing
they're different flavors of ice cream
they're all [ __ ] ice cream
so if you tune into our direct path
video you might be tasting
chocolate ice cream and if you tune into
some of bentino's videos you might be
tasting vanilla ice cream
and you might be tasting strawberry ice
cream with rupert spyra and whatnot
and so that's why you can tell that
these things are there's a perennial
wisdom because why else
would they all be [ __ ] ice cream
why else when i listen to rupert and i
listen to bentino and i look at the sufi
metaphysics and the laozi and i go and
take entheogens and all those things
look at each other and look at me
as well that we all say that yeah it's
just all pointing to the one end on
these different colors or these
different paths
wake up to that wake up to that
that is the single most important thing
that this planet can awaken to is
literally the perennial wisdom it's
literally a timeless truth
it's been here forever and it'll
continue being here
but we're lost in maya we're lost in the
illusion we're lost in the dream
we're lost in the physicalism believing
that we're
finite contracted egoic separate
entities
and we're the fish that is literally
seeking the ocean that it's already
in but we don't see the diamond necklace
around our neck
and we don't see how it's a unique
refraction of the source light
just like your pupil and the iris just
look at somebody else in the eyes
just look at somebody else in the eyes
for an extended period of time
silently without moving without laughing
and just look at their pupil silently
for several minutes
and you will see the kingdom of god
within them they will see the kingdom of
god within you
train yourself to do that instead of
seeing a separate entity
it's the same [ __ ] observer looking
at itself
through both of you
but everybody gets there to the one end
across all these different paths in
their own time
i would not have understood any of this
five years ago even three years ago
now if i was trained when i was five
years old with the
vr pedagogy of god realization
then i would have picked this [ __ ] up by
the time i was 12 which is why we're
making that so that we can get teenagers
to be god realized
or with the kogi mamas if you want to
take a spiritual perspective that's not
necessarily technological and scientific
like with virtual realities and whatnot
you can just take the kogi perspective
you just be born
into complete darkness for your first
nine years of your life in a cave
what do you think that's gonna do to you
probably make you an
absolute shamanic jedi
there's not going to be any separation
when you get out of that cave
you're going to know that you're one
with everything you're gonna know that
this is infinity expressing itself as
these creation designs
you're gonna know that you're gonna know
what the ineffable is you're gonna know
what the absolute is you're gonna know
what
the even the people you surround
yourself with
are going to be people that know those
things as well you're not even going to
encounter if you're up in
the sierra nevada de santa marta in
colombia or
if you're over in the
though in the african vodoon traditions
over in
west africa or if you're in the
australian aborigines traditions and
if you're across any of these
temples or monasteries up in the
mountains
across zen or zogchen
or any of these
what's going to happen is you're going
to recognize that the people around you
are not egoic contracted entities they
are blissed out
pieced out people that recognize
that the observer is shared and that
they're transcending
even the observer itself to the absolute
the observer is god and they're
transcending even that
that's what the perennial wisdom is
all right so now what we're going to do
is we're going to take
from this kind of like direct path
level where we've had this breakdown
from the i am this to the i am to the i
i and to the beyond i we're going to
take this to the
level of where we're mostly going to
talk about
only the i i or the i am
to the beyond i to the absolute or the
infinite that type of thing
so this is the quote highest level of
like that direct path teaching and so
this is why this episode was very timely
and i wanted to share it because i had
just done an exegesis not only
of his teachings over the last year and
whatnot but i had also done
an exegesis of his recent
most comprehensive understandings of how
to transcend even the observer itself to
the absolute
which is where i'm at as well in my path
and so it's really resonant all right
so you can find all of these on our
instagram
simulation series we posted them there
and i'm really grateful to
gabrielle as well you can find her link
in the bio below to her instagram but
she's the one that
makes a lot of these posts and her
handle is at
lovin l-o-v-i-n dot
gabrielle g-a-b-r-i-e-l-l-e
and you can go follow her and support
her and then bentino's instagram is also
down there
but let's start with this one okay so
this is the higher level direct path
teachings that are really resonant with
me
as i'm undergoing this process of
understanding what that
infinite consciousness is and how to be
able to transcend even that to this
absolute to this infinite
and so
there's even a lot of nuances with
even just using the word infinite
because many people use infinite
consciousness to describe the observer
or the witness itself so when you say
the absolute and then you add the word
infinity to that
again there's just so much around the
nomenclature the lexicon the semantics
of these things
but ultimately the absolute is
absolutely ineffable indescribable it's
attributeless and it's agentless
and so there's nothing you can [ __ ]
say about it you just transcend
the observer itself you transcend god
itself the seer you transcend that
and that's when you taste the absolute
it's way simpler than it's actually
really simple once you sort of get to
your satori
everything becomes simple in the last
month everything has just clicked into
place and become ridiculously simple
i've went through these upgrades in
satori as well where
i've been just adding to the satori over
time and it's becoming more and more
clear and more and more
just profound and once once you
pierce the veil of surveiller the
gateless gate you get it it's done you
don't even need a gold star from a
teacher to have them put it on your head
you just get it it's
done the only thing you can do after
that is literally just
you know continue doing the reps with
your discernment
that's it and just surrender to the
absolute
that's channeling through and
recognize yourself as that eternal
that's being colored by what this unique
expression is
your iris your unique source light
refracting through your diamond necklace
so
let's unpack these higher level ones a
bit together
so this first one is truth is not
an experience but a rejection of all
experiences
this is natural clarity of the highest
order the illusions of experiences
simply slide
off of you by power of natural
discernment okay we were just talking
about that
literally your experience of the clouds
or
of the ocean waves themselves
that is not truth truth is your
ability to reject even the clouds
even the waves and you okay then you
recognize okay
my natural clarity is the peace
and the happiness of the eternal
consciousness
that is being colored by those things
okay and then you recognize even more
that
all of it even slides off you're not
moved by any of it it doesn't move you
anymore you
feel things massively you have high ass
sensitivity
you have way more subtlety than anybody
that's in the gross or the physical
way more way more to be able to
transcend even
the observer or god or the witness
itself
requires a massive amount of subtlety
the most subtlety
and so nothing is able to pierce your
equanimity
you're just imperturbably peaceful done
end of story done you recognize the
illusion of those appearances
done
transcend even the experiencer and
penetrate the absolute
infinity glimpsing itself beyond
nothingness and everythingness
preserve the highest discernment
liberate yourself from the carrots of
maya
okay so in this case it's
clear that as we just talked about a
moment ago
we're transcending even the experiencer
and that's how we're penetrating the
absolutes infinity glimpsing itself
beyond nothingness and everythingness
i'm still trying to understand you know
beyond everythingness
being the everything of all that is and
then the nothingness
is the everything is no
thing
everything is an appearance or an
illusion or a dream
in god's brain
and so going beyond even the nothingness
and the everythingness beyond the all
that is and beyond the dream it's
dreams themselves
that's it
and bentino said in his recent direct
path video he said even
the
even oneness is suffering
in itself because you become attached to
being all that is
you say that oh i'm oneness i'm all that
is and then you just become the entirety
of all that's happening that's a state
that's a stage
it's important but at the same time
don't become attached to it
also understand the nothingness of all
of the dreams
how the dreams are illusory that's
another more advanced stage and state
and then even beyond both of those two
together is something else
where you transcend even the observation
of those two things
and just liberating yourself from the
carrots of maya the carrots are all over
the place
keep the high discernment and liberate
yourself from the carrots that are all
over
always trying to tempt you always trying
to tempt you
is crazy they're always trying to tempt
you
and the wiser you get the less you're
tempted by them
maya is here to drive us home suffering
is the absolute gps guiding us back to
itself
in the final state there was never any
suffering or experience
so again maya is the drill sergeant
of suffering and so that illusion
in itself is teaching us about how to go
and pierce the veilus veil and to turn
inward towards consciousness
and that's the absolute gps guiding us
back to itself
and then in the final state there's
never any suffering or experience
because it's all a dream in god's brain
that's all it is it's an illusion it's
an appearance it's a dream
use the i am to remove all form based
thorns
from the i slash i until penetration of
the absolute which removes even the
original thorn of foreverness
okay so once you get beyond the i am
this to the i am what you're gonna do is
you're gonna
slowly or quickly become better and
better at removing the form-based thorns
from that i slash i
meaning that you're gonna have all these
scenarios that happen to you
in the world where those scenarios are
going to
lead you to become a victim to the cloud
again and you're going to remove those
form-based thorns
you're also going to remove the
form-based thorns of materialism and
conspicuous consumption and clout
chasing
and fame and fortune and wealth
and
and sexual fantasies because
those don't serve your enlightenment
anymore
and then you penetrate the absolute
which removes even the original thorn of
the foreverness of the witness itself of
awareness itself
so awareness is the original thorn from
the absolute the original thorn from the
absolute
is awareness
the original thorn and then everything
else is a downstream
thorn of physicalism
in these creation designs
does a world appear apart from
experiencing
knowing god directly is a simple shift
from the experiences
to the experiencer the seer
guys this one is just ridiculously
simple if you want to move from the i am
this to the i
am all you have to do is recognize the
seer
that's all you have to do stop focusing
on the experiences
themselves and and focusing on the
experience
sir that's why saint francis of assisi
said that which you are seeking
is what is seeking itself
so you can't keep going out and seeking
externally
because you're literally seeking the
seeker itself
recognize that that which you seek is
what is seeking
that's what the diamond necklace is that
rumi talked about
to wake up to that is liberation true
liberation
we're at a whole new level of planetary
ignorance
with the
complete immersion in maya without even
understanding
the elusive the illusion of it the
appearance of it the dream of it
complete unprecedented levels of maya
right now
because there's eight billion of us
that's a thing if before there were only
a hundred million people
that's not that much maya well it's a
lot of maya but
you know it's not like 10 maya
but it's still like you know 95 million
maya or whatever
you know now today we're talking like
7.8 billion
maya or whatever and it's [ __ ] crazy
that that's how many people are stooped
in
the illusion and a bunch of them maybe a
billion of them
have this seeking impulse and they're
trying to
find the diamond necklace already around
their neck
but they're doing it part time they're
doing it like oh i think that
if i just dedicate one hour a week
to watching a youtube video i will
become enlightened
no [ __ ] that's not how it works
dedicate 40 50
60 hours a week non-stop to this [ __ ]
build up that lattice work
watch all of the direct pass stuff read
all of the books of the mystic
traditions attend all of the meditation
retreats go and do anthogens do
everything build up your lattice work
seek
until your ass falls off
until you literally break through the
veils veil and you experience satori
that's the only way to do it
that's what we'll get to here in a
moment with the one step
being unstable
or be lost in the labyrinth of your own
creation if you want
it's not a problem that's the whole
point of non-duality
is to say that you can be there's no
being lost
if you want to be a contracted egoic
entity that's
exactly what it is and that's it and
there's no additional words to add to it
now in the dualistic concession you say
that that ego contracted entity is
what's destroying the planetary ecology
and that that ego contracted entity used
to wake up
to god realization so it stops
destroying the planetary ecology
that's the dualistic concession of the
mountain so that it go against
turn back around and pursue these
different paths up the mountain and
build up this lattice work and
understand what the
infinite consciousness is and what the
absolute is
it's that there's so much amnesia
there's so much forgetting
right now of even eternity
everyone's stooped in time time is the
illusion that's destroying
people's understanding of eternity and
so it's making everyone feel
finite and that's why we're convinced
that ah this world appears apart from
experiencing
no [ __ ] god has to be the
observer
that is [ __ ] experiencing
you can't you can imagine dreaming
at night and while you dream at night
it's just the dreamed world but there's
no observer in it
what the [ __ ]
you can't dream a dream and there not to
be an observer in it
that's experiencing it there would be no
experiencing then
duh wake up it's so
[ __ ] simple it's right under our
noses
these analogies oh my gosh they're so
simple
they're so simple a [ __ ] kid can get
it a kid that dreams
can understand the nature of reality
and then just throw them into vr god
realization technology
at the age of five and it's game over
dude
they will no longer serve the corporate
hypnotists that have been brainwashing
civilization for millennia
come and serve your king the king of
money
come and serve the king the king of
conspicuous consumption
don't you want the car don't you want
the house
don't you want the hot girl don't you
want the drugs and the alcohol
don't you want the clout and the fame
don't you want all of that
come and work for us come and work for
us
come and work for us
yeah i want that and by the time you're
80 years old you're like
dude i didn't [ __ ] live a moment of
my life
that's the current nature of our reality
and there's a very very very very small
portion of people
that will be like [ __ ] all that noise
that's a bunch of [ __ ]
and then they'll be the ones that are
like okay now what is real
what is the true nature of reality what
do i have to seek okay
seek inward okay oh [ __ ] i got it i'm
the observer god's the observer everyone
is that got it
and what oh there's an absolute we can
transcend even that observer
that process itself is gold that is the
gold of the planet that is the gold of
the planet
everything else is illusion it's maya
it's a dream
everything else is that which is fine
again in the non-duality if you want to
be immersed in that
go for it not a problem but if you want
to awaken to the true
nature of reality and at the same time
solve the planetary
ecological disasters and maximize
flourishing for everybody
god realize because then it will become
effortless
stay at the threshold of oneness god
experiencing all that is and the
unknowable absolute prior to it
okay so again we're at that threshold
you are now god you are the observer but
there's different varying degrees of
being god the observer
so a lot of the time i will spend
in just god the observer and then i will
expand myself to being the
god consciousness god observer that is
the observer of all eight billion
on this creation design so i will expand
myself
out to the awareness of the
consciousness that is experiencing
through all eight billion so it's the
one awareness of the consciousness
experiencing through all eight billion
so if you practice that then you're at a
really high level of consciousness and
then you can go one more level of
consciousness
above that which is where you hold the
awakeness or the awareness or the
consciousness
of not only this creation design but all
of the creation designs
that's what all that is means
now if you hold the position of
experiencing all that is which is
already [ __ ] crazy
that in itself is nuts then you reject
even the observation of all that is
and that's the absolute
now you can tell why we saved this for
the end this is the hyper advanced
part of the direct path and neoadvita is
trying to point people directly to this
and it's a little bit unstable which
we'll talk about here in a bit
okay here's another way to say the same
thing again
the homeomorphism stabilize
god realization then leap
beyond to before this stream of
experiencing
okay this is what the absolute is
stabilize the god realization and you
can even do this
in the god realization of just the
single observer recognizing itself as
god and then transcending even that
now if you do it at the level of the
entire creation design here and all of
the creation designs then that's
really [ __ ] nuts because that will
take you to another level of holy
[ __ ] there's all of those dreams that
are happening of creation designs
and you transcend the observation of
even that
so not just this local creation designed
to transcend the observation of that
but of all of the creation designs
leap beyond to even before that stream
of experiencing
the observation of the creation designs
all right so now we're getting to the
end
where we're going to talk about the
difference between what's unstable and
stable
jumping direct to absolute is unstable
since their mirror of consciousness god
is distorted slash
polluted upon purification and
consciousness meditating on itself
even the observer god becomes an object
rather than the subject
okay what this means in essence is that
to jump directly from the physicalism
like we saw in that first graphic
right here to jump directly from i am
this
physicalism all the way to the absolute
to the beyond eye
is unstable because literally the
mirror the purity
of your observer of that
is steeped in ego if you are still in i
am this you are still in ego and so for
you to be an ego
and to go under the process of being
like ah i'm an ego but this is all a
dream
well probably time for me to go make
some money
maybe i want a car but it's all a dream
but i still want a car but i still want
a house but i still want a hot woman but
i still want to
rule the world
it becomes unstable because you haven't
dissolved the ego
knowing that it's a dream and being in
the ego
are not mutually exclusive they
yeah they are not mutually exclusive
things
they do not have to happen differently
they have they
you can be both simultaneously you can
still have an ego and be the absolute if
you
take and recognize that it's a dream
you're not absolutely recognizing it's a
dream
all right you can be
in a state of egoic consciousness have
the direct path pointed to you
of this being a dream and then stay in a
go at consciousness
while knowing it's a dream there we go
that's the best way to put it
now what is more stable is if you go
from the i am this to the first step
which is understanding
infinite consciousness or infinite
awareness itself
recognizing the very i am-ness that's
the ocean or the sky that's experiencing
the clouds or the waves
and that's why upon purification what
you do is you
decrease the distortion in the pollution
you eradicate that
and that's what makes you even more of a
pure
observer you meditate more and more on
the observer and you
clean off the distortion and the
pollution off of your mirror
because we're all mirrors of god we're
all mirrors
of that we are that or another way is
where the diamonds and your diamond can
not be shining so much because you have
this dirty pollution on it
and so you have to rub it clean and by
doing so you're automatically going
inward more and more as well
and then what happens is you purify and
you become
more and more stable in the realization
of god consciousness
and then what you do is you transcend
even god consciousness
and you recognize that as an object
rather than the subject so god
consciousness becomes an object
and you're there at the absolute
the shit's [ __ ] whack all this is
[ __ ]
whack it's nuts it's beautiful it's
crazy
it's trying to use symbols and words
to describe the ineffable
which has been done for thousands of
years by the vedic rishis and beyond
but it's crazy [ __ ] being in this
position myself
it's so crazy being here myself
it's like oh my god in like
you know being being 19
you know if i would have stayed in south
dakota or minnesota instead of coming
out to california to silicon valley
right or if i didn't go to my
you know 10 day meditation retreats or
if i didn't take those entheogens
or if i didn't take the year off to try
and
go 100 full time into seeking truth
i wouldn't be here right now i would
have no idea what the [ __ ] i was doing
[Music]
still
and now we're all the way at the level
of talking about transcending the
observer that is god
as an object
it's [ __ ] crazy
it's so [ __ ] crazy
there's literally nothing i can do
anymore besides this i can't do anything
any
anymore besides this there's nothing
else i can do
once you've got realized all you can do
is just try your best we talked about
this on the episode
fred davis all you can do is
understand that a this is ineffable done
zip b the coolest thing to do
is to be able to try and use symbols to
describe the ineffable
and that's why we're doing this right
now
that's all i can do now because it's the
coolest thing to do i can't do anything
else nothing else is as cool as this
this is the coolest [ __ ] game in town
is trying to use symbols
and visuals and try and put this into
books and vr
pedagogies and animated series and
documentaries and anthologies and all
this type of dope [ __ ] which is why
we're in la to do exactly that
oh my goodness gracious
and you recognize that as well that the
wind
is both the wind and the wind is also
the coolest thing to try and capture
and put into art somebody might ask you
you know why are you trying to capture
the absolute why are you trying to
capture it
what else is there cooler to do besides
try and capture the absolute and put it
into art
dude that's by far for me the coolest
thing to do around the diamond necklace
around my neck and its unique expression
if you want to go and surf and you want
to do that
great just recognize that if you're not
god realized and you're surfing
you're also potentially the person that
is undergoing the process of doing
something
that is maybe you're flipping out at
your spouse
and you're you're the unconscious parent
that is driving egoic onion layers onto
your child
that's the thing you can do whatever you
want whatever your
little expression of infinity is but
recognize that by god realizing you
automatically
bring peace and happiness to
effortlessly to everything around you
so you can basically surf and you can
not
have an ego yay you can do whatever you
want
and not have an ego whatever it's
calling you to do
all right and i think there's two more
so it seems the stable
way to the absolute is through god slash
i
am slash all-inclusive experiencing
and this is when i knew that you know
bentino
knows this is when i knew
you know this whole bentino masara's
direct path was a little rough around
the edges with some of the
intro stuff about him and also with
around some of the direct path
his most formative like last six years
of trying to understand this
but this specifically
was published yesterday by
me and in doing so i knew that i had to
do this video
because bentino knows he just knows
you know when other people know and they
know when you know
and it there's just nothing to say
and then what you do is you try and use
symbols to say it for fun
and this these types of statements is
what makes me know he knows
it seems the stable way
to the absolute is through god slash
i am slash all-inclusive experiencing
again the word it seems first is really
important so it seems
right so it's like i'm not locked in it
seems because i'm
the continuous learning as well the
stable
way so he's trying to make the stable he
understands that there are unstable ways
to the absolute and those
are what we described earlier
as well which can create the ego that
understands that this is a dream
to the absolute is through god slash i
am slash all-inclusive experiencing so
he's even giving us
the what it's through so it seems
the stable way to the absolutist through
god i am all-inclusive experiencing and
he's trying to give you all these
different
ways to understand it which is why we do
that on the show as the spiritual
synthesis
as well is that it's god or i am or all
inclusive experiencing
pick whichever one they all represent
that same thing colored differently
and so in this sense taking on the god
or the i
am or the all-inclusive experiencing of
not only your own understanding of your
own
observation point but also the
observation points of
all of god on this creation design and
then the observation points
through the awareness of all of the
observation across the creation designs
that are happening
period in all that is
and then you reject even that you
transcend
even the observer and you become
agentless
and this was another major
this nailed it for me i knew that he
knew
because there's so many people that are
lost in neoadvita
there's just no simultaneity in neo
advaita it's like neoadvita
it's teaching is very much like
hey you're in a dream right now this is
all an appearance
you don't exist and then it's like the
ego's like
uh
okay you know that's like the you know
sometimes there are these revelatory
breakthroughs don't get me wrong there's
like hundreds of people that wake up
through that process as well
but
the one step the neo advice appointing
may be unstable the one step
but the two step which is first to i
am and then to absolute anchors it
and that's what you see here where you
take the first step from the physicalism
to the consciousness the awareness that
i am-ness that godness
the observer the witness that's
experiencing
the clouds rather than being the clouds
the finite clouds
you are the eternal infinite observer
itself
experiencing that coloration
and then you take the next step which is
transcending
even that to the absolute you transcend
even all eight billion here on the
creation design in all creation designs
in summation you transcend
even the observation of all that that's
the absolute
here's the creation design here's you as
a physical separate entity
then you go i'm not the physical
separate entity and you go
okay i'm the awareness i'm the eternal
awareness
and then you go okay cool so there's a
shift from outward to inward okay you
got that
the next thing is i'm not just the
observer of my
of this experience but i'm the observer
of
all of the experiences that are
happening right now
through all of the observers that
observer is shared so then that
that point takes on the observation of
all 8 billion here
on this creation design and then that
gets expanded even further to all of the
creation designs themselves
and that's what all that is is and then
you take the observation of all that
experience and you go
nope
there you go and that's what's stable
it's just honestly stable that's it if
you
want to know the nature of your reality
if you want to know the topology the
landscape of the nature of reality then
do this two-step process aka
god realize and then absolute realize
that's the process go from the physical
to the eternal observer and then go from
the eternal observer
and reject even that to the absolute
that's the process
it's as simple as that
again go from the contracted egoic
separate finite physical entity to
the observer that is eternal lee
being colored by the experience so
you're the sky
being colored by the clouds in the sky
is eternal
it's been here it'll keep being here
that's the point of these creation
designs
and then you transcend even that
observer itself you are agentless at
that point you are
attributeless at that point no
attributes
no agent
all right
well i'm glad that we were able to get
into the nuanced details across
all of these posts again you can find
all these posts on
uh simulation series on instagram again
huge shout out to
lovin gabrielle she's so awesome go and
follow her her links in the bio below
and then also bentino massaro his uh
instagram's down there as well go and
give him a follow
and i'm really happy we were able to hit
this really high level
stuff as well so it's not just the
direct path of the first
stage and the second stage and whatnot
but it's really the direct path all the
way up to the highest stages and these
these um this most recent exegesis
really did it and then even these going
over these
initial graphics of the direct path that
ventino's been able to synthesize and
distill for us
have been really insightful for me and i
hope also
for you as well this is obviously what
we're working on here
at simulation and all of our other
artistic distillations of the
topology the landscape of the nature of
reality as well
so we're aiming to get them even more
refined than this to put them into
vr pedagogies into
into animated series and
documentaries and all this type of stuff
and so this one's really insightful
and then this one as well especially at
the level of getting to the i am from
the physical
and then this one which really boils it
down
super duper boiled down
and then this one again if people can't
hear you
if people can't hear you are that one
infinite absolute formless perfection
beyond all experience
can you hear that you are that one
infinite absolute formless perfection
beyond all experience
done done
done you are that one infinite absolute
formless perfection beyond all
experience
if you're going to try new symbols be
precise like that
and if people can't hear that move on to
you are pure awareness which many people
understand not many approximately spiral
dynamics and levels of consciousness
tell us somewhere around like 15 percent
of people understand that which seems
still pretty high
but if they cannot hear that i suggest
they focus on being present beyond their
ordinary thoughts which
probably fifteen percent of people know
how to do and if they cannot hear that i
suggest they discover their calling
purpose and align everything to it
probably closer to like 20 25 percent of
people are doing something like that so
or maybe closer to something like
maybe 60 percent of people are in some
sort of a
process of either creating whatever they
want or
just having that process of of being
hypnotized
into mass ignorance which is quite clear
just go to your local park
and just go people watch or even worse
if you really want it go to your local
bar
and go people watch
but this is our creation design this is
our experience
and it's beautiful the way it is and at
the same time
we do recognize in the duelist the
concession that we want to awaken we
want to enlighten
and that's why we make art like this and
again so grateful to bentino so grateful
to his team they're doing a great job
with this type of stuff
super super thanks everybody for tuning
in
love you tons super grateful for those
that tuned in i hope
it brought you massive value like the
video if it did subscribe if you haven't
already leave your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you about this
again go and subscribe to bentino's
youtube channel go and check out his
mirror talk series go and check out his
global enlightenment retreat as well
that he did in 2020
and also check out bentino massaro.tv
he's got a lot of other great content on
there
go check out the trinfinityacademy.com
as well
he has a great breakdown of
self-realization self-actualization
it's really really strong and it's
obvious he's been doing it 10 years
i've been doing it a month you know and
but we have our unique angles on this
and
that we should be grateful for people
like him that step
up and that say that after having the
satori i'm going to make this robust
understanding of what self-realization
is
and then share that with the world and
continue doing that process
and being in service and it's beautiful
and also go and support gabrielle again
loving.gabrielle on instagram she does a
great job with his quotes and
many other great spiritual quotes as
well
all right that's all folks i love you
infinitely thanks for sticking
in with this it's been a big ride a big
joy to do this episode
and it's been really insightful for me
uh
even to take me to the next levels which
is
the first reason why i do this in the
first place is for me
for an artistic expression of this it's
doing me
it's doing these and then as a secondary
thing
if it brings you value that also brings
me happiness it brings me peace
and so i hope it did and
share it with other people if it did
especially the ones that you know will
resonate with
and let's popularize the nomenclature
right
let's popularize these graphics these
visuals let's popularize the idea
of transcending the physical
infinity and transcending that to what
is the observer or the witness or the i
am or the self or
god that is experiencing
the waves or the clouds as the ocean or
the sky
right let's get to that first one as a
civilization as the first step
and then we'll transcend even that to
the second step of the absolute
that thorn of the awareness itself
but we have to turn inward first so
let's popularize this let's get this
deeper into our media our education
systems
and that's up to us to make the art to
push the messages out there
and it's beautiful and i'm really
grateful and it's already just
absolutely indescribable it's all
ineffable and i adore it and it's the
coolest thing
trying to do to be able to put these
symbols on it as close as possible and
i'm really grateful to you bentino
i'm looking forward to meeting you at
some point in the near future and also
being able to
go back and forth with you on shows as
well
uh across our shows that we host and
across both of our shows because it's
going to be really strong i have a
feeling it'll be a really strong
friendship brotherhood i also have had
these visions even dating back to last
year
where you and i even in 2019 where
bentino and i you and i
were together like on this
on the level of tony robbins having the
massive sort of
stadiums which is one of the visions
that i had in 2018
of filling sports stadiums for these
massive awakening events
but then into late 2019 and through 2020
it came up several times where you were
there with me
doing it together which was very
fascinating and it makes sense that
you know i'm gravitated to you as a
spiritual synthesis
because i am as well i'm gravitated to
you as somebody that has clearly
experienced satori
and that understands these things and
that now that i have as well
now it's sort of my turn to be able to
artistically formulate them
and i'll keep sending them over to you
and the rest of the team
and uh i'm looking forward to all of
that collaboration and co-creation it's
really beautiful
and to everybody that watched
again infinite love thank you so much
and
pierce the veilless veil
god realize
and transcend even that to the absolute
you